people always ask me dude do I have a
gizmo do you have a gremlin in your
closet they always ask me things like
that and I think they're surprised at
the answer and for those people who
don't follow me on Twitter and why
aren't you
but at zwg man when I was doing the
second one I didn't drive for the first
one they took me there in a van because
I grew up in New York so I didn't have a
driver's license but for the second one
I had a car and I would drive in and out
of the Warner Brothers lot and every
night or day when I would leave the
Warner Brothers security would make me
pop my trunk and they would search my
car to make sure I wasn't like trying to
Nick a gremlin which is I always thought
it was kind of amazing I was like do you
really think that I am good as and
they're kind of like well no one would
suspect you so yeah so they checked my
trunk every single time I came on and
off the lot without fail so even if
they're like four months of shooting and
be like hey guys they're like hey open
your trunk I was like wow just not
giving me any love at all it was amazing
no I'm not I'm not gonna steal anything
like that especially when they're giving
me so many nice things anyway well like
I got to keep for the first one I got to
keep the sword I gave that away I just
gave that someone was like I want that I
was like you know what what am I gonna
do there's gonna be a thing on the
internet called eBay I'm gonna sell it
on it oh wait there is so I gave it away
yeah so I had the sword
I had the chewed-up baseball bat at home
I have a prop the Daniel clamp book from
gremlins 2 where it's like john glover
sitting there and posing in the cover so
i have one of those what was your
favorite part if you look back on that
time filming those two movies but you
know for me the favorite part of any
movie that I do is just the people that
I'm working with and hanging out with
them and forming the friendships and the
bonds and all those kind of things that
hopefully you know lasts for a while you
know sometimes an entire lifetime so so
yeah I'm
I'd like to think of myself as a people
person so I mean I I like making friends
and and for forming relationships like
that you know that's that's the most
rewarding part
you